good afternoon everybody just a few
things to pass along here and then we'll
get right to your questions
today secretary Austin is directing
multiple immediate actions following the
suicide prevention and response
independent review committee's
recommendations and establishing a
suicide prevention implementation
working group
the department continues to recognize
the importance of addressing and
preventing suicide within the military
ranks
immediate actions to be taken stemming
from the committee's recommendations
focus on improving access to Mental
Health Care through initiatives such as
Expediting hiring for behavioral health
professionals expanding opportunities to
treat common mental health conditions in
primary care and improve utilization of
behavioral health technicians these
actions aim to strengthen the well-being
and support available to our service
members worldwide
notably secretary Austin has also
directed The working group to give full
consideration to all of the other
recommendations provided by The Suicide
Prevention and response independent
Review Committee
and the implementation working group
will provide him with their own
subsequent recommendations on the
feasibility and impact of each one of
the implementation in an implementation
plan excuse me due to the secretary by
June 2nd
while we recognize that suicide has no
single cause and that no single
preventative action treatment or cure
will eliminate suicide altogether
we will exhaust every effort to promote
the Wellness Health and morale of our
total Force
be there for one another and save lives
additional information about dod's
suicide prevention implementation
working group and secretary Austin's
direction is now available on
defense.gov
switching to the National Guard chief of
the National Guard Bureau General Daniel
Hokinson visited centcom this week to
formalize the Arizona National Guard
State partnership program relationship
with the sultanate of Oman
General Hokinson was joined by Arizona
governor Katie Hobbs U.S ambassador
Leslie Sao Arizona National Guard
general Major General Carrie muhlenbeck
and a delegation of Arizona Guardsmen
for a formal signing ceremony in Muscat
Oman
the National Guard State partnership
program which celebrates its 30th
Anniversary this summer has grown to 88
Partnerships with 100 Nations
engagements between states and their
International Partners improve Readiness
and interoperability and contribute to
security and stability around the world
for more information about this new
partnership or the state partnership
program I would encourage you to reach
out to the National Guard Bureau
separately in order to meet U.S army and
Europe and Africa Mission requirements
improve command and control capabilities
and manage foreign forward operating
sites within the Republic of Poland the
U.S army will establish the U.S army
Garrison Poland in March 2023. Garrison
is one of the enduring improvements to
the dod posture in Europe based on
assessments from the 2021 Global posture
review and consultations with NATO
allies and announced by President Biden
in June of 2022.
joining the existing seven installation
management command Europe Garrison's U.S
army Garrison Poland will deliver
quality-based operations support
infrastructure and services to soldiers
and civilians to enable U.S army and
Europe and Africa command readiness
the unit will be comprised of
approximately 13 military personnel and
140 civilian personnel installation
management command Europe and U.S army
Garrison Poland look forward to the
continued strengthening of the bond
between our military community and the
host nation communities of Poland at the
local Regional and National levels of
the alliance for additional questions I
would refer you to the U.S army
and finally yesterday secretary Austin
and general Millie hosted the 10th
session of the Ukraine defense contact
group where 50 nations of Goodwill
participated from all over the world
this showed the continued commitment
that is indicative of the strong unity
and resolve of the International
Community to support Ukraine and their
fight to defend themselves and their
sovereignty from Russian aggression as
secretary Austin and other U.S leaders
have said we will continue to support
Ukraine for as long as it takes and with
that I will take your questions we'll go
first to AP Tower cup
hi thank you for doing this
um I was hoping you could talk a little
bit more about why the Pentagon decided
to declassify the video of the Drone and
whether or not releasing it you know
increase the risk of Russia framing this
conflict instead of being a conflict
between Russia and Ukraine but be being
between Russia and the West
yeah thanks Tara so first of all it's
not unusual for us to release imagery of
unsafe unprofessional incidents we've
done that in other situations uh and so
particularly in this case uh given the
Reckless and dangerous behavior and to
demonstrate uh publicly
what type of actions the Russians had
taken we felt that it was important to
provide this imagery certainly there are
certain considerations that we have to
take into account when dealing with
imagery to include the classification to
ensure that we're not inadvertently
putting out sensitive information but in
this case we were able to work through
that and provide that as far as you know
Russian perceptions again I think it's
important to take a step back and look
at the big picture here the United
States focus in the region the focus
with Ukraine is solely on providing
Ukraine with the support that it needs
to defend itself you've heard us say
before that Ukraine has a right to
defend itself and we have a right to
help them alongside the International
Community to do that so so the United
States does not seek conflict with
Russia we do not seek escalation with
Russia and so we're going to continue to
stay focused on our primary mission in
the Ukraine area which is supporting
Ukraine in its fight
to declass declassifying the video and
releasing it
you know Russia has suggested that it
didn't show the actual contact
UM
how does this really just counter that
narrative and show that this happened
the way that the Pentagon has said it
has yeah well I I think that our words
and our actions speak for themselves and
similarly Russia's inaccurate
information false information obsecution
grasping at straws changing narratives
also speaks for itself so we're going to
stay focused on the facts and we're
going to stay focused on our mission let
me go to the next question Liz
first part of my questions are um did
the U.S ask for an apology from Russia
on taking down the Drone and did Russia
offer an apology
no we did not ask for an apology again
our Focus was on highlighting the fact
as we've made very clear publicly and
privately that the United States will
continue to fly and operate in
international airspace in accordance
with international law
second part is um
come out that Russian officials ordered
the pilots to be aggressive towards the
Drone and today the centcom commander
told the Senate armed services committee
that he's seen increased Russian
aggression in the Middle East is this
something that the U.S is concerned
about does the U.S have any promises
that Russia will decrease its its
aggression uh so Liz what I would tell
you is that again our focus is on
conducting our operations in support of
our national security interests our our
allies and our partners around the world
ultimately the Russian military and the
Russian government is responsible for
its own behavior and when that behavior
is unsafe and unprofessional we're going
to call it out as we've done in this
case and so that it will continue to be
our Focus uh you've heard secretary
Austin you've heard General Hecker in
Europe and others call on the Russians
to be safe and professional in
conducting their operations and that
would be the expectation going forward
thank you will
um so secretary Austin has said that um
the U.S will continue to operate to fly
wherever international law allows in
light of that has the U.S operated mq-9s
over the Black Sea since um since the
collision and crash
so I'm not going to get into talking
about uh specific missions routes
timelines of operations I think
secretary Austin was pretty clear that
we're going to continue to fly and
operate in international airspace or
International allows and that includes
the Black Sea region
Travis
uh thanks Pat I had a couple questions
about the suicide working group I think
I heard you say that the secretary is
immediately implementing some of the
recommendations that the working group
is going to be looking at the other
recommendations I just wanted to confirm
whether the
um recommendation for new restrictions
on the purchase and storage of personal
firearms on base is included in the
first tranche or if the working group is
still considering thanks Travis that'll
be something that the working group will
examine in further detail and come back
to the secretary with with their
assessment and their recommendation and
if I could just follow up on the
recommendations that the secretary did
decide to implement why did he choose
those specific recommendations sure so
those those recommendations are are
primarily focused on behavioral and
mental health there are areas where the
department already has the authorities
necessary to take immediate action and
and so that was the primary driver was
of those recommendations what are the
things that we can move on right now
that will make a difference for our
service members thank you you go over
here row and then I'll come over here to
Chris
uh thank you General uh two questions
first that Japanese prime minister
kishida met with South Korean president
Yoon today in Tokyo and agreed to
normalize their bilateral relations how
much do you expect the Improvement of
their bilateral relations will benefit
the Pentagon to address challenges posed
by China and North Korea
yeah well uh thanks for the question Ro
what I would tell you is that we
certainly welcome the discussions
anything that is going to help
strengthen our alliance as you know
Japan and South Korea are two of our
strongest allies and so we welcome any
opportunity for us to strengthen our
unity and to work together for a free
and open indo-pacific
our secondary there is a growing number
of North North Koreans missile ranches
including the one that including ICBM
that they launched yesterday
are you concerned that this high
frequency of of their missile ranches
will be a new normal that we have to
live with for a while
well again I think uh the the
overarching important uh aspect of all
of this is that the United States along
with South Korea Japan and our other
allies and partners in the region will
continue to work together to ensure
stability and Security in the
indo-pacific region to include
addressing the destabilizing activities
of North Korea and so we're going to
continue to keep a close eye on that I
think at the end of the day we all want
to see a region that is stable that is
secure that is safe and that will be our
Focus North Korea clearly is concerning
in that regard but it's something that
we're going to continue to work on
together and to deter potential
aggression thank you let me go to Chris
and then we'll come back here
thanks Pat Uh yesterday chairman milley
said the U.S was confident no sensitive
material was compromised in the drone
incident
um what does that mean was the Drone
remotely wiped was there a self-destruct
mechanism was it crashed in such a way
that it would obliterate any material
that could be yeah uncovered thanks
Chris uh so so a couple things
um
so
first of all we do have indications that
and I think you've seen some reporting
on this we do have indications that
Russia is likely making an effort to try
to recover MQ-9 debris
as you point out and as general milley
highlighted however we assess it's very
unlikely that they would be able to
recover anything useful given a couple
of factors one the fact and I'm not
going to go into details but that we
took steps to protect information aboard
that aircraft and two the fact that it
crashed in extremely deep water and so
um I'll just leave it at that
does the U.S view the an MQ-9 as a
particularly sensitive platform or is
well the key Point here is this is U.S
property and it's an intelligence
surveillance reconnaissance asset and so
again we have capabilities and means at
our disposal to protect and Safeguard
information of which we have taken but
I'll just I have to leave it there so
let me go here and then I'll come back
there and then to Casa
to the middle yes yes ma'am
yep right in front of you there if you
can hand her the microphone there you go
thank you
we're about a month and a half out I
think from the the new briefing room
Okay so yesterday uh General Millie's
stated Russia is increasing relying on
other countries
Iran and North Korea is North Korea
still supplying munition to Russia
have we seen anything yeah thank you for
that so I don't have any updates to
provide other than we do know as you
highlight that Russia continues to to
seek Munitions from countries like North
Korea but I don't have any new updates
to provide in terms of any specific
transactions
well I think we've talked about before
we had evidence of Wagner group
obtaining some Munitions from North
Korea we know that Russia is seeking
additional ammunition from North Korea
and Iran but again I don't have any
details to provide today and then my
second one is trying to get in closer to
sending lethal uh Aid to Russia have you
seen any final decisions evidence of
actual shipments yeah so at this time we
have not seen uh the transfer yet of any
lethal assistance
from China to Russia for use on the
battlefield is something that we're
keeping a very close eye on I know
there's some press reports out there
talking about some trade deals that in
and of itself is Not Unusual China and
Russia share a trade relationship but
the key point being is that as of right
now we've not seen any lethal assistance
transferring from China to Russia for
use on the battlefield in Ukraine
artist that can help the Wagner group or
Russia
uh I don't I don't have anything on that
thanks all right let me I was going to
go back to the middle there this
gentleman he's been very patient and
then to qasim
thank you Pat today the Senate votes to
proceed with the repel of the
authorization for the using Force
against Iraq
to what extent do you agree with this
Congress members that are supporting to
end this act and
how this act
affects your capability to face and
respond the threats that comes from Isis
and also the other terrorist groups in
the future to you forces in Iraq and
also your partners in Iraq yeah thank
you um so what I would say right now is
I I don't want to get into a discussion
about or comment on pending potential
legislation other than to say that as
always we'll work very closely with the
Congress to ensure that we continue to
conduct our operations in accordance
with law thank you
concerns that if the if this act will
end it in the Congress or amended there
are some members of the Congress says
that this will
affect the U.S capability to face the
threats that comes from Iran that's why
they are not supporting to ending this
act for now yeah no and I appreciate the
question but but you know we'll allow
obviously the the Congress to do its
work it just would be inappropriate for
me to to engage in the legislative
debate of course the department will
stay in close contact with the Congress
as one would expect and you know we'll
continue to be a part of those
discussions thank you let me go to
custom
I have a follow-up and then I have a
separate topic
Russians are making efforts to to
recover the the MQ-9 so Russians
initially aggressively moved over to a
U.S capability and downed it and are now
making efforts to recover it and then
what we hear from this department is
quite a soft uh expression of concern
um we even haven't heard you condemning
Russians and just saying that it's
unsafe unprofessional what are we
missing there
uh because I'm not sure what your your
question is I think we were pretty uh
vocal that the conduct of the pilots was
unsafe and unprofessional it was
Reckless it was dangerous secretary
Austin spoke to his counterpart General
milley spoke to his counterpart again I
highlighted the top that our focus is on
conducting our missions in the region in
international airspace we're focused on
protecting and defending the NATO
alliance and also on supporting Ukraine
in its
I'm not gonna I'll let you put words to
it custom of course we have highlighted
that it is a unacceptable act but if you
if you're looking for hyperbole I will
leave that to you okay
I suppose questions sorry General
um today
um a helicopter
um a mysterious helicopter was crashed
crashed in Northern Iraq and it came out
that it was carrying a pkk elements my
question is does the United States
provide helicopter piloting training to
SDF Partners in Syria or not not to my
knowledge
no we do not thank you buddy
thank you general just want to follow up
on the uh drone issue incident so
first question yesterday uh the last
assessment we heard is it's not clear
whether
um this Collision was intentional or not
uh do you have an update on the on this
assessment uh whether the Russians did
this on purpose and the second question
is
um the indications that the Russians
might might be trying to recover some of
the degrees
you talked about deep water in the Black
Sea but are you ruling out
um maybe the Russians being able to use
some technology or divers to be able to
recover the debris thank you yeah thank
you um so so on the latter part of your
question I don't want to speculate again
this is U.S property but it's our
assessment again that it is very highly
unlikely that even if they were to
recover it that there would be anything
useful in that regard in terms of was
this intentional I'll tell you what we
know and what we don't know we do know
know that this aggressive behavior was
intentional by on the part of the pilots
whether or not they they hit the drone
on purpose we don't know but it clearly
demonstrates uh either
poor airmanship or Reckless Behavior
because just from an Airman standpoint
why would you hit another aircraft with
your aircraft in the sky and and so
again Reckless dangerous unsafe
unprofessional behavior which is why
again we have called on the Russians to
conduct their operations safely and
professionally thank you
come back here
let me go here sorry Joe we'll go here
and then we'll go here
I have two questions uh first questions
Senator Mitt Romney and Jin Shaheen
reintroduced there by partisan
legislation that would direct the
administration to develop a strategy
toward the Black Sea region so do you
believe General that the recent strategy
need to be developed or more be specific
uh thank you for the question so we
would need to take a look at that I
don't have that in front of us you know
clearly uh we uh have a forced presence
around the world uh and take into
account under the national defense
strategy uh why we're operating where
we're operating I can tell you that when
it comes to the Black Sea uh it is a
critical International Seaway that
supports many of our NATO allies uh and
and so we're going to continue to
operate over that that area for the
reasons that I highlighted in support of
our NATO alliance and also as we conduct
ISR operations in there as as part of
our national security interests thank
you
military officials are saying that the
they see Russian increasing its Marine
presence in the Black Sea what will be
your reaction is it need to be there in
a higher up tempo as well thank you um I
I really don't have a comment on that
it's not surprising that Russia
maintains a presence in the black see
they have for some time but I I don't
have any specific comment to provide on
on Ukraine's assessment let me go to Joe
I think so much um at the risk of
splitting hairs on the aumf question
um could I ask what is the secretary's
position on aumf repeal not um
necessarily your position but the has
the secretary been asked to weigh in on
Capitol Hill what's his position on
repeal yeah again without getting into
the pending legislation the secretary is
certainly supportive of any discussions
that Congress would have on the aumf
thank you I'll go to row
yep
thank you so much Janelle I have
follow-up question on North Korea why
U.S and ROK conducts military exercise
North Korea reacts hashary and launched
icvm yesterday how do you think U.S are
okay biograph cooperation and U.S ROK
Japan's trial their security Corporation
can work to deter North Korea's further
provocations okay um let me just make
sure I understand so you're asking in
light of North Korea's provocations how
can a Japan
South Korea U.S Alliance exercises work
is that is Overture yes so North Korea
reacts to the U.S rok's military
exercise so how such kind of security
cooperation can work through the Eternal
career right so I think again it's it's
important to just kind of take a step
back here and the exercises that the
United States conducts with Japan and
with South Korea are defensive in nature
and meant to bolster our
interoperability and meant to deter
potential aggression in the region and
so that's first and foremost and so in
terms of North Korea's
reactions to these types of exercises uh
as you heard me say before not only is
it inappropriate it's destabilizing and
and concerning clearly to those in the
region but I think what's important for
people to understand is one deterrence
continues to work
despite launching missiles into the
ocean North Korea is not attacking and
nor should they and that the United
States Japan South Korea and other
allies and partners in the region will
continue to work together to extend that
deterrence and to keep our country safe
again with the ultimate objective here
being a secure safe prosperous free and
open indo-pacific region thank you mosh
thanks back to the MQ-9 is there any
indication that the Russians have
already picked up debris from the area
I've seen some press reports to that
effect but I can't corroborate any
information whether they have or have
not
and then separately have have allies
offered to send units to help with the
recovery efforts
um I don't have anything to announce
mosh I'd allow our allies to to speak
for themselves in that regard in terms
of uh U.S recovery operations uh as
you've heard us say we're assessing
options but I don't have anything
further on that right at the moment one
more really quick has the U.S requested
a transfer through the Bosphorus Strait
not to my knowledge yep
Matt
time for a few more here thank you Pat
on that wreckage has the U.S or will the
U.S make any requests of the Russians
that if they're able to salvage any
significant portions of the MQ-9 that'd
be returned as a matter of good faith
and has there been any discussions of
recompense given that this is a quite
expensive piece of equipment
but not to my knowledge
General Mill yesterday
talked about this incident as part of a
wider pattern of behavior
by Russia is there any indication that
you see that this incident and others
like it are coming from a standing order
or being encouraged in any way from high
levels of the Russian government
yeah thanks Matt so uh so the short
answer is I I don't know
um you know clearly uh as uh General
milley highlighted we've seen an uptick
in this type of aggressive behavior
um but whether or not this is a
coordinated effort I I couldn't tell you
what I can tell you is that it's wholly
inappropriate it's unsafe and it's
unprofessional the stakes are high this
is why it's important to keep the lines
of communication open to prevent
potential miscalculation and we'll
certainly do uh our part in that regard
to continue to fly sail and operate
safely and professionally around the
world thank you all right okay last
question a few more
go ahead sir
thank you Junior I'm Taro from Nippon TV
so yesterday North Korea launched
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
it's for higher than 6000 meters for
about 70 minutes so that dld think any
aberration of this kind of Technology
again it's something that we obviously
observe every time North Korea conducts
a launch we closely observe it monitor
it but I'm not going to get into the
specifics uh on on their capabilities or
talk about our assessment of those
capabilities thank you and last question
yes ma'am
thank you in recent weeks Republican
Congress members have stepped up
criticism if you will at the Pentagon
about about wokeness and press senior
DOD officials over things like pronoun
training I'm saying a hyper political
culture has invaded the military does
the Secretary of Defense have have a
response to this and are there any plans
to address these concerns yeah so so I'm
not going to get into what individual uh
political members members of Congress uh
those running for office are saying I'll
just give you uh the perspective of the
department and the perspective of the
department is that today's military is
the most combat credible capable force
that has ever existed on the planet
every single day we have thousands of
our military members around the world
conducting operations very important
operations in very dangerous places
doing incredibly important work which
speaks for itself and so as a 30-year
member of the military I can tell you uh
that we are very proud of what we do and
how we present ourselves and how we
defend this nation and I think I speak
for a lot of others in that regard thank
you very much everybody appreciate it